- Un dialogue de sourds devenu
un peu plus bruyant...
maintenant que l'avortement
n'est plus un droit protégé
par la Constitution américaine
Un consensus est illusoire.
Cette jeune femme voudrait que
Cette jeune femme voudrait q
les manifestants anti-avortement
fassent preuve de plus
"Essayez-vous de comprendre
se faire avorter? demande Shifa,
venue de la Virginie,
ou tentez-vous d'imposer
vos doctrines religieusesvernems
où il y a une séparationavec lÉ"
Develda, venue du Texas, croit
que les personnes anti-choix las
soient déprogrammées, dit-elle,
et ceci n'arrivera pas au cours
qu'ils sont constamment
Ces mè
bombardés de message religieux."
Ces mères de familles disent
qu'elles ne se tairont pas,i s't
contre l'avortement.
Chacun demeure campé
sur ses positions :
"Vous voulez commettre des
meurtres, dit ce jeune homme.
sécuritaires."
"Toutes les vies ons tous une vs
ne devrions pas être tués,
venue de l'Indiana."
Le président américain Joe B
a réitéré son soutien aux femmes
en ajoutant que cette décision
pour les Américains.
"Mon administratioera
sur la légalité des loi édictées
par les gouvernements
anti-choix, explique le'interdin
de se rendre dans un autre État
pour obtenir des soins
de santé."
Partout au pays, les Américains
"Si vous souhaitez que
en Caroline du Sud,
ez passer à l'action."kson, au ,
où l'avortement sera bientôt
interdit, les manifestantstenter
le personnel d'une clinique.
se creuse un peu plus entre
les deux
convaincu de détenir la vérité.
Ici Valérie-Micaela Bain,
Radio-